Larger people. They're eating better.
You know what I wanted to ask you please.
Conspiracy theories. I know you
have some. Yeah, I got something.
I felt like I was listening to you about
what is something about Martians the
other day that was a proud
Papa Johns Jones is Alex. Alex,
amazing NASA shirt. I was gonna
buy for Eddie the other day. Yeah,
Alex wore a NASA. Yeah. Yeah. Hey Eddie,
believe she had that even
Alex thinks is ridiculous.
Like what quits conspiracy theories do
you want to know about it? No, I'm like,
let me hear some, well, I believe
less than, less than I ever used to.
Population control. Do you believe
that? No, I don't believe that.
I don't believe there's
any concerted effort. Um,
it like where there's a bunch of
really rich people that have decided to
euthanize a bunch of people to keep
the population low. I think that is,
that's paranoid. I think that
there's probably some people that go,
you know what? We would be a lot
healthier if there was less people,
but there's no,
there's no obvious effort.
The population keeps fucking growing.
Imagine if you are the all powerful,
all knowing people that were running
the world and you're doing such a shitty
job of population control.
Yeah.
I don't know how you're going to
control the India and China. You're not,
you're not.
You're not.
You're not getting in these fucking dirty
villages and trying to stop being not
doing it anywhere.
And even in this country,
people are fucking like wild
animals and just come in next month,
you guys got three kids. Yeah.
Like, look, it's just the way it is.
Mad People like to fuck.
They like to make people in China.
You're only allowed one kid. No, I think
they lived that. They've left lifted,
lifted that because a lot of people were
drowning their daughters. There were,
there was horrible shit.
Wow. You're killing, I mean,
this is the rumor was that people were,
they wanted a son and if they had a
daughter they would, you know. Yeah.
The daughter was like the law,
the law. The lose for you. Yeah.
And to me a daughter is a win because
there's so much easier to deal with.
Really. I find with my daughter,
I'm, we're, we're like this.
Yeah. You know what, man?
I mean,
just be of a boy coming next.
You got to have the ying and the Yang.
Little Joseph Lennox Lewis.
Peter's coming next month. Hey,
I'm Joseph Lennox Rogan Peters.
He's going to be amazing. I'm so
happy that you gave him my name. Yeah,
that's beautiful. Cave at first is
going to give me your middle name,
but I didn't want to do that to him.
So what's your middle name? Whoa. Yes.
My middle name is Claudius. Claudius.
Yeah. That sounds like a Roman emperor.
Absolutely beautiful. Hey Man,
I know you're supposed to get out of here
at two o'clock. Do you have a hard out?
No, no. You can say. Yeah, absolutely.
Beautiful. Let's keep talking. Yeah. Um,
yeah. So back to your
question. I don't, yeah,
I think there's definitely some people
that are influencing the way the world
works for sure.
But I don't think there's anybody that's
really trying to control population or
this one.
Okay.
Do you think the Russians put Donald
Trump in the president's chair?
I think the Russians absolutely wanted
Donald Trump to win. Absolutely.
And I think they definitely undermined
our democracy through various methods of
manipulating people through social media.
In fact,
I have a woman coming on very soon. When
is Rene de Resto this week? Next week.
She's on next week. And uh, she
actually studied it and wrote,
wrote this very
comprehensive report about,
it was on Sam Harris' podcast and detailed
millions of interactions with Russian
bots and Russian fake accounts and that
these troll farms that we'd create memes
and they did,
they did a bunch of different things.
They didn't just try to pump Trump up,
but they also tried to get people
against each other and cause all sorts of
civil, uh, arguments and all
sorts of, uh, on rust. Yeah.
All sorts of unrest online.
They organize these meetings like they
organize one pro Texas meeting across the
street from a pro Muslim meeting.
I did it on prime,
that did it all through Facebook to get
these people to fight with each other.
They're doing these things to try to get
people to take sides and to get people
to be angry at the other side. They did
a lot of shit like that. Real sneaky,
sneaky stuff that we probably do
in foreign countries all the time.
And you know,
we're mad that they're doing it to us
because now they're doing it through
social.
Yeah.
Well if you think about when we were
growing up in the eighties seventies and
eighties all the imagery we saw,
the USSR was very dark and gray and it
was very barren and it was destitute and
well, some of it was true though. Yeah.
But we saw and then all of a sudden
that lifts and these hot fucking Russian
chicks show up.
What were these bitches is the whole time.
That's so true.
You never saw the hot Russian league.
There's some of the
hottest women on a plan.
They used to show us these big manly
women will do well. And now you're like,
well, hello. Hi. Yeah. Yeah.
I have two friends in America, Russian
ladies. They're very happy. No,
the question cause because you're
American, everything. I'm not American.
So is this wall, if we're going to get
built towards that, what's the situation?
I don't,
I think it was more of a campaign
rhetoric thing. You know,
build that wall, build that wall.
He's kind of staying with it. I mean,
I think he wants to porters, I think
he's got a kind of do something right.
Once you say that, you're gonna build a
wall, you got to kind of do something,
but they ain't shit been built and
we're two years into the president.
They haven't built shit.
I was a year left in the year and a half
left in the presbytery is some wall,
there's some wall. It's up. But
there's all some big ass gaps. And the,
the idea that they're going to stop drugs
from coming over from that wall right
now, the wall looks like Leon Spinks
his mouth. I don't have a bench.
I forgot about Leon spanx.